juste à l'action de petit con et le
collier se lâche sofia se sent prête à
ouvrir son propre fait pendant son stage
la boutique écoles de la quinière est là
après tout la réglementation les
techniques de vente et des petites
astuces pour être une bonne commerçante
voici multitâche quand on a une boutique
on avait pu évoquer notamment aussi
l'agencement d'un magasin la mise en
valeur d'une vitrine femmes toutes ces
petites choses qui font que voilà c'est
pas par hasard qu'un commerce fonctionne
ou pas il ya des techniques assez
pointue des outils qui sont à
disposition
cette boutique école est au coeur du
quartier de la quinière à blois
elle est financée à hauteur de 20 mille
euros par l'état et la commune dans le
cadre de la politique de la ville ce
sont les intervenants de l'association
vge ismer qui assure cette formation
gratuite
leur spécialité l'accompagnement dans la
création d'entreprise corner c'est
important pour nous d'être implantés
dans des quartiers comme celui ci pour
quelque part redynamiser aussi un
quartier une vie de quartier une vie
locale et permettre à des personnes qui
habitent ces quartiers d'avoir accès à
de la formation
pour elle ça va changer des choses
soient elles partent sur ce projet de
boutique elle se sent beaucoup plus à
l'aise beaucoup plus confiante en elle
soit elles se disent c'est pas fait pour
moi et elles vont repartir dans le
salariat
donc oui ça change les choses je pense
que le fait d' expérimenter vraiment de
jouer ce rôle de commerçante il est
fondamental après trois semaines de jeu
de rôle est de mise en situation les
quatre stagiaires seront confrontés à la
clientèle à partir de mardi
la boutique éphémère sera ouverte
jusqu'au 15 décembre puis elle devrait
réouvrir en mars pour une seconde
formation